- And I think people skills
tend to be highly underestimated
in terms of just ability to run a company.
Guys, I'm going to major
in computer science
and one of my friend said, wow,
that's the stupidest
thing I've ever heard.
And like they come at me again,
you anonymous quote me?
(audience laughing)
- I can't wait to get an anonymous quote--
- (chuckles) I kill you!
Our goal is to be the most
important venture capital firm
in the world, following your passion
is a very me-centered view of the world.
Work is what's important, it's that effort
where you learn the secrets.
I wanted to quit every day
(chuckles) I was in that job.
I felt like throwing up when
I woke up in the morning.
But you only get leverage if the person
that you hire can do
it better than you can.
If you're a technology
entrepreneur, you've got
every opportunity to make
like a gazillion dollars.
Like all the VCs and everybody tells me,
Ben, you know what the
key to a great company is?
Hire A players.
- He's an American
businessman, investor, blogger
and author, he's the co-founder
of the venture capital firm
that bears his man, he co-founded
the enterprise software company Opsware
that Hewlett Packard
acquired for $1.6 billion.
He's Ben Horowitz and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
(zapping)
(thunder rumbling)
- Yeah, so in the world of
entrepreneurship, the big skills
are programming skills and people skills,
like (chuckles) those are
the big two and I think
people skills tend to
be highly underestimated
in terms of just ability to
run a company and so forth.
And what I mean by people
skills is the ability
to understand other people's motivation
and other people's motivations
who you're talking to
and then who you're also
not talking to and how
they're going to think
about something and where
they're coming from and
relate to that in a way
that gets you to the right
conclusion about you build
an organization or build
a company or make a deal
or any of these kinds of
things as incredibly valuable
and that's what I would say
most of the good entrepreneurs
end up lacking more than the
technical skills that we see.
Now being like a boss-level
engineer, that's extremely
valuable, I'm not
discounting that but that's
really the other big, big
skill that you can learn.
And I was just so excited
to tell my friends.
I as like, man, they're going
to be just so fired for me.
I figured it out, I'm not
going to be stressed anymore.
I'm like, guys, I'm going
to major in computer science
and one of my friends said, wow,
that's the stupidest
thing I've ever heard.
(audience laughing)
And I'm like, why, he's like,
you're at Columbia University.
That's like a trade, you
could learn that at DeVry.
They'll teach you how to build computers,
fix them, program them.
(audience chuckles)
You should major in something real.
And I was just thinking to myself.
I was like I'm talking
about a limitless machine.
You're talking about a washing machine.
(audience laughing)
But I was so frustrated, I
couldn't even really explain
to him why but it was at that point,
at my height of frustration that I learned
the most valuable lesson
that I learned at Columbia,
which is don't listen to your friends.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheers and applauds)
And the more generalized
case of don't listen
to your friends is think for yourself.
And thinking for yourself
sounds both simple
and trivial but in reality,
it's extremely difficult
and it's profound and here's why.
As human beings, we want to be
liked, it's anthropological.
If people didn't like you in caveman days,
they would just eat you.
(audience chuckles)
So you really have a
natural built-in instinct
to want to be liked and
the easiest way to be liked
is to tell people what they want to hear.
And you know what everybody wants to hear?
What they already believe to be true
and so the last thing they want
to hear is an original idea
that contradicts their belief system
so it's very hard to bring
that kind of stuff up
but those are the things,
those are the only things,
things that you believe,
that everybody around you
doesn't believe, when you're right,
that create real value in the world.
Everything else, people already know.
There's no value created,
it's just business as usual.
So it's so important
to think for yourself.
- How do you get along with other VCs?
- So (chuckles) this is funny
so (chuckles) I get along
with them very well so there are VCs
that I really, really like,
Neil Bu-zree is one of them
who I work with all the
time on various deals.
I just got off the phone with Ted Schlein,
who I get along with very, very well
so there are a lot of
VCs I get along with.
I'm a bad cultural fit for
investing, you may have noticed.
And then there's a good reason for this
so if you think about the
investing environment,
it's this weird coopetition
thing because you compete
for deals but you work on deals together
so you're kind of partners
but you're competitors
and I don't come from that culture.
I come from enterprise software, right?
Like you know who the top dog
in enterprise software is,
Larry Ellison, right,
like ain't no co-petition
in Larry Ellison, right?
(Sarah and audience chuckling)
All you have to do is
mention anybody's who's close
to a competitor and his head will blow off
and he'll go bananas--
- Speaking of a deal,
we saw that at D with Workday.
- Yeah, he just went absolutely banana.
It's like it's on, baby!
(Sarah laughs)
It's like he stepped on my shoes.
Let's go, and so for me, and then also,
I listen to Little Weezy.
(Sarah and audience laughing)
And so sometimes, the venture
capitalists with come at me
being friendly, hey, with the peace sign.
And to me, the peace
sign is just the trigger
and the middle finger, you know?
(Sarah and audience laughing)
- So that's what I mean.
That is from Weezy.
- (chuckles) Does it bother you
when they talk shit about you?
'Cause they don't do it to your face.
They do it to people like me.
- It's anonymous, so yeah, that was,
you're alluding a little
bit to when I called them
cry babies, which gets
actually another thing.
The one thing that does
bother me a little bit
about some VCs and some
angels, so one of the things
that's happened a lot since
we've been in the industry
is we get a lot of people
calling the press anonymously.
They are probably more
anonymous quotes (chuckles)
about us in the press than
any other entity right now.
And Sarah calls me up and she goes,
Ben, I got a tip from six
different anonymous angels
saying that you're doing
this and I'm going,
if they don't like what I'm doing,
why don't they just come out and say it?
(Sarah chuckles)
Like if I don't like something
somebody's doing, I just come out.
I put my name on it and
the reason that bothers me
so much is the number
one thing we look for
in an entrepreneur and the
number one thing that I encourage
and I try and help people
develop is courage.
And the reason that that's important
and it's very, very important
and it goes back to Aristotle,
so Aristotle said courage
is the first virtue,
and the reason it's the first virtue
is if you don't have it, then
you don't have any virtue
because all these other
things, honesty, integrity,
whatever, don't ever get activated
when they're important if
you don't have courage.
It's easy to be honest unless
it's going to cost you your job
or your marriage or
something you care about
then it's hard to be honest.
So without courage, you
don't have integrity.
You don't have anything,
you're just like the,
you're a zero-character
person and so when people
who are supposed to be
coaching entrepreneurs,
angel investors or VCs walk around giving
anonymous tips to reporters about stuff
they don't think is right, and those guys
are advising the people I'm working with?
That really, that's
something that pissed me off
so like I'm not having it
and I'm going to call 'em
on it (chuckles) and
they come at me again,
you anonymous quote me (chuckles).
(audience laughing)
- I can't wait to get--
- I kill you!
- An anonymous quote tomorrow.
- Did you imagine you'd be
managing almost five billion?
- So one of the things we
knew from entrepreneurs
and this is very, very key
point on entrepreneurship
is that it is just as much
work and just as traumatic
to build a company that's
trivial and nobody cares about
than it is to build a really
significant important thing.
It's the same amount of work,
so you might as well try to do
something important.
(audience chuckles)
And so that was always
our thought with the firm.
We were like, we are going
to like, our goal is to be
the important venture
capital firm in the world.
Like I said, it's completely
megalomaniacal and arrogant
and idiotic but that
like, if you don't have
that attitude as an
entrepreneur, you should not be
an entrepreneur, so, yeah,
(chuckles) we were always
going to be the biggest, we
were always going to be the best
and that was the goal and
there was no reason to exist
if we weren't going to do that.
What I'd like to give is a
few unconventional graduation
thoughts and I'm titling
them do not call your passion
and the world is not going
to hell in a hand basket
and the Class of 2015 is
not required to save it.
(audience chuckles)
I told you it was going
to be unconventional.
So don't follow your passion.
Now, you're probably thinking
that's a really dumb idea
because everybody who's
successful and if you poll
1,000 people who are
successful, they'll all say
that they love what they do
and so the broad conclusion
of that world is that
if you do what you love,
then you'll be successful
but we're engineers
and we know that that might be true.
But it also might be the case
that if you're successful,
you love what you do, you
just love being successful
and everybody love you, it's awesome.
(audience laughing and applauding)
So which one is it?
Well, I think to figure it out,
you have to go back in time.
You have to back off
when you were successful
to right now, when you're
graduating as the Class of 2015.
And the first tricky thing about passions
are they're hard to prioritize
which passion is it.
Are you more passionate
about math or engineering?
about history or literature?
Are you more passionate
about video games or K-pop?
(audience chuckling)
These are tough decisions,
how do you even know?
On the other hand, what are you good at?
Are you good at math or writing?
That's a much easier thing to figure out.
The second thing that's
tricky if you're going forward
in time with this follow-your-passion idea
is that what you're passionate about at 21
is not necessarily what you're
going to be passionate at 40.
Now this is true for boyfriends
as well as career choices.
(audience laughing)
The third issue with
following your passion is,
excuse me, a little
trouble with the throat,
'cause you're not necessarily
good at your passion
and has anybody ever watch American Idol?
So you know what I'm talking
about, just because you love
singing doesn't mean you should
be a professional singer.
(audience laughing)
And then finally and most importantly,
following your passion is
a very me-centered view
of the world and when you go through life,
what you'll find is what you take
out of the world over
time, be it, whatever,
money, cars, stuff, accolades,
is much less important than
what you put into the world.
And so my recommendation would be follow
your contribution, find the
thing that you're great at,
put that into the world,
contribute to others,
help the world be better and
that is the thing to follow.
It's funny, sometimes I
talk to my wife about this
but hard work is super important in life
and now, I grew up in Berkeley,
I didn't have any money.
I played football for the Yellow Jackets.
I was just like a kid in the neighborhood
and now, I have a lot
money and so with my kids,
I'm like, okay, now that I'm rich,
how do I teach you the value of hard work?
'Cause that's really the
only important lesson
that I've got, but for
all of you, I think most
of you out of public
university probably know
a little of the value of hard work.
Keep that lesson, that
work is what's important.
It's that effort where
you learn the secrets
that are super valuable and can change
people's lives and change the world.
- But why did you still
believe in the company?
I have to think that at any
point in Silicon Valley history,
there's a lot of people
that at that point,
they're just like, this
isn't going to work.
Market's changed, this isn't
a viable concept anymore.
- I don't know how much
belief I had but I knew
that I had gotten everybody
into the boat with me
so it wasn't so much that
I didn't want to quit.
I wanted to quit every day
(chuckles) I was in that job.
I felt like throwing up when
I woke up in the morning.
(audience laughing)
- (chuckles) So you know
what's it's like having
a baby now (chuckles).
- Yeah, exactly.
Like I felt like I was pregnant
but I'd hired every employee
and they all trusted me.
I'd raised all the money,
I talked to every investor
into putting their money
in, I had given stock
to my friends and relatives
and they were all excited
about the prospects for the company.
When it went public
like a lot of my friends
from high school bought the
stock 'cause I was running
the company, and so I
felt like I could die
but I couldn't quit and one--
- Wow.
- Of the horrible things
about being founder
CEO is it's the one job
you really can't quit or if you do quit,
you're a punk.
(Sarah and audience laughing)
And so I didn't want to be a punk
so I just kept peddling.
But it was rough, I mean
that was, running LoudCloud
(chuckles)
Right? And it didn't stop
there, right, like that
was LoudCloud (chuckles).
LoudCloud, by the time
LoudCloud was 2 1/2 years old,
I had sold the LoudCloud
part of the business
and I had to change it into
another business (chuckles)
so the next thing that
happened was LoudCloud
was going to go bankrupt,
so I raised $160 million
in the IPO but we burned through that
and we couldn't stop the
burn because the customers
kept going out of business
and so we were headed
towards bankruptcy so then I had to,
I sold (chuckles) the
services part of the business
and all the cash part
into EDS and then I had
to lay off probably another
third of the employees
and then I kept the remaining 80 employees
and we became a software company,
a publicly trade software
company with no customers
and no revenue, which was another trick--
- That was when you became Opsware.
- That's when we became
Opsware, yeah, so that was hard.
(Sarah and audience chuckling)
But it was good, it
had that kind of stuff.
It makes you strong.
(Sarah and audience chuckling)
Eventually, five years later,
we sold to Hewlett Packard
for $1.6 billion.
- Not a bad exit.
- Which was still, I'm still
shocked by that whole thing
(Sarah and Ben chuckling)
I still wake up
in the middle of the night going,
are we going to run of money?
You only get leverage,
and this is something
that is really tricky for
founding CEOs to get to,
but you only leverage if
the person that you hire
can do it better than you can
because as long as you feel
like you're better than them at it,
then there's not, you're just
going to keep second-guessing
them and you're not going
to get any leverage.
And a lot of the times,
I'll be talking to CEOs
and they'll have an executive
and they'll be like,
oh, this person's really
good and they're working
really hard and I'm like, well,
but you're always frustrated
about, you always feel like
you have to do that yourself
and it's like, yeah, 'cause
they don't understand
how to do this and that, and I'm like,
well, then they're not an executive
because the whole point of an executive
is to get you leverage and
so on a question like that,
it's like okay, where can
you find the right person
and make the hire to get you
leverage, and wherever that is,
that's what you should give up first.
And you want leverage on
all spots because as CEO,
you can be the keeper of the vision,
the quality control over
the top but you can't be
the lead engineer forever, there is no,
and it doesn't matter
how good an engineer,
like Larry Page, as great
an engineer as he was,
is not an engineer at
Google, he just isn't.
And he cannot work on
production products (chuckles).
It's a full-time job, even
for somebody who can do
as many things as Larry, he cannot do that
and nobody can, like if Larry can't do it,
you can't do it either, I guarantee you.
(audience laughing)
And so you're going to
have to give them all up
and so it's just a matter of
where do you get the leverage.
All of the general partners in the firm
basically agreed that we would
give half of our money away
to charity that we earned at the firm,
basically half of everything we
get, we're going to give away.
And here's why, here's why,
let me just say why we did it.
The world is complex
and it can't be entirely fair
from what you contribute to what you get
is very, very uneven and
even if you just look
at Silicon Valley, if you look
at the kind of brilliant
people at Stanford Hospital
or some of the people
who build the buildings
that we live in or the
guys who teach the kids
at the teachers at the
schools are incredibly smart
and dedicated but there really is no way
that they're going to ever
make anything like what I make
at Andreessen Horowitz,
it's just impossible
the way society is structured.
There's no way it could
happen but their contribution
to what I do is significant, without them,
I've got kids that are in those schools.
I get sick, I go to those doctors.
I live in that environment
and I appreciate it.
I really appreciate
the effort and the work
and what they do and so
for me to be in a position
where I can put money into
the resources that I share
with them and make their
life a little easier,
I just feel like it's
the right thing to do
so it's nothing more than
that and I don't there's
any kind of way I can give
money to other people.
If you're a technology
entrepreneur, you've got
every opportunity to make
like a gazillion dollars.
That opportunity is
there whether they invest
and get a percentage
of your company or not.
But if you're a teacher, you
don't have that opportunity
but, man, if I can get you
the resources to do your job
better so that you've
got a little more space
in your classroom, that
could make a difference
for a kid who can do something
that's really important
and so that's what I'm
about and that's what
I'm going to do and I'm very
proud that our whole firm
is doing that with me.
- The Hard Thing About
Hard Things, which is just,
where did that title come from?
(chuckles)
'Cause that's just
a way cool title, The Hard
Thing About Hard Things.
- Well, actually, I
wrote that title myself,
which I understand is actually pretty rare
in the book business that they
let you keep your own title.
But where it came from
was when I was the CEO,
it was easy time, I slept like a baby.
I woke up every two hours and cried.
(audience laughing)
- (claps) I need a drum
roll (faint speaking).
- And you know what, when I would be up
and (chuckles) this is not a
joke, this is actually true.
You can ask my wife, I'd
be up at three o'clock
in the morning just sitting
there going why are none
of the management books
that I'm reading helping me?
They are no help at all
and I read literally
every management book and I
realized that management books
are generally written for here's how you,
to not screw up your company
but if you start a company,
that lasts like a week and
then you've screwed it up
and then where's the book for that?
(audience chuckling)
And that's what was missing
so I would think about it.
I'd be like okay, yeah, so
all the VCs and everybody
tells me, Ben, you know what
the key to a great company is?
Hire A players.
(audience chuckles)
And I'd be sitting
there like, okay, great,
'cause I was going to hire a bunch
of (bleep) idiots.
(audience laughing)
And now you've unlocked the
secret for me, thank you.
But that wasn't like way and
I was like the hard thing
is not to hire the best people, right?
The hard thing is when your
company is going like this
and the great, best people
don't want to work for you
and then who do you hire
and how does that work?
Do you hire the person
who's okay across the board
or do you hire the person
that's got something
horribly wrong with them
but super great about them
and how do you think about
that and what do you do
with the horribly wrong
stuff once you get them?
That's the hard thing and
there's I read the Jim Collins
books, which I hate.
(audience laughing)
(chuckles) Some of you like them, I know.
It doesn't mean you're
not smart if you like them
because a lot of smart people like them
but the thing that he does
is he makes you feel good
about yourself but then
when you get into it,
you realize cause and
effect is all swung around
in all these things but he's like, big,
what great companies have is
a big hairy audacious goal
and I think that's great
but that's no hard.
It's pretty easy to write a big hairy,
like we're going to go
to the moon, you know?
We're going to build the
biggest company in the world.
We're going to have
software on every desktop.
It's all going to be ours,
like that's our goal.
Okay, so now you've missed your goal.
(audience chuckling)
And not only did you miss
your goal but you built
up your whole company
to achieve your goal and
you have a cost structure
that's designed to hit your
goal and you've missed your goal
and you're running out of
cash and the company's burning
to the ground and all the
company, everybody that works
for you thinks you're a moron
because you missed your goal.
Okay, that's hard (chuckles)
like that's a hard thing.
What do you do there, well,
that's not in Jim's book, he
didn't even talk about that.
(audience laughing)
It's like nobody ever misses
our goal who's a great company
so why would you miss your goal?
You must not be great.
(audience laughing)
(laughter drowns out voice) Jim so anyway,
that's where The Hard
Thing About Hard Things.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
FBGM 247 asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the top 10 rules
is going to have the
biggest impact on your life.
Leave it in the comments and
I'll join the discussion.
And if you liked this
video, my personal goal
on this channel is to help
reach a million subscribers
so anything you can think
of to help share the videos,
spread the message, I really,
truly, deeply appreciate it.
Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
(zapping)
(thunder rumbling)